yeah thank you everyone for coming so I
feel very honored to be the only speaker
in this sessions I get my own presenter
which was nice
so today I'm going to talk about so I
made me work in functional data analysis
but I sort of do a little bit here and
there with privacy so I'm just gonna try
and not load too much into this talk and
just sort of discuss some functional
data problems and maybe moving away from
Gaussian distributions using what are
called elliptical distributions to try
and come up with some privacy framework
so I don't load a ton of stuff into my
talk so if you ever have a question just
don't hesitate to ask it I don't think
well run insane problems in it
if Maxime wants to come up to the stage
he can as well so this is a joint work
with Jordan I wanna be's talking later
today right yeah okay and so Jordan did
that it's done a really nice job on
these projects and has been really
patient with me in terms of insisting on
weird technical details that we should
prove so it's done really nicely and
also grateful to NSF okay so this will
be fairly standard so I'm just gonna
talk a little bit about some examples of
functional data analysis just some
examples that are close to my heart that
I've worked on and so I sort of always
give these same examples these days I've
updated them maybe like every two years
or something
and then I'll talk just a little bit
about sort of a motivating example for
sort of a statistical problem with
functional data analysis and privacy and
then I'll get into some details on
elliptical distributions and then we'll
sort of finish with discussing privacy
where there's some good news and some
some bad news or bad news for in my
it's maybe not like a full-on tragedy
but it's this there's some interesting
problems that come up okay so this is
the my first example of functional data
so these are coming from electronic
health records so these are pediatric
populations so I have children that
they're sort of monitoring from these
records from birth up to it looks like
about hundred nine hundred days or so
and this is this is a study on macro
Stephanie
so that's having an overly large head so
pediatricians will be quite concerned if
there's some sort of abnormal growth in
the head size not necessarily because
the head is large but because that could
be a sign that something else is going
on and so this is sort of what scans
what's called sort of sparse functional
data you can think of a sort of
longitudinal data sort of the same idea
but it's it's fairly sensitive but we
it's a very interesting data set so we
have lots and lots of data so you can go
up to 74 thousand children although for
microcephaly when we have 85 cases and
you might even for something like this
you might even start getting into some
genetic factors and so on alright so
here's another example which is not
quite as erratic so this is from a study
called insight which is being conducted
out of Hershey Pennsylvania which is
where our medical school is which with
the meta school next to the Chocolate
Factory instead of the University and so
what we have here is that we have again
children aging over time and here we
have weight for height trajectories okay
so they're interested in understanding
childhood obesity and they can sort of
have these nice fairly well sort of
humanely designed data and so here
they're interested in starting the
children but they don't they have sort
of interventions they want to understand
how these interventions are affecting
the development of childhood obesity and
they also have a bunch of other fun
information so they have like microbiome
information and genetic information
all right okay so here's my last example
so this is sort of a very regular but
sort of sort of a weird functional data
example and so I haven't talked about
how these are functional data yet to any
folks in privacy but if it something you
want to talk about we could so the basic
idea is for this study is that this is
being carried out by Mark Shriver who's
also a Penn State and anthropology so
he's collected data on tens of thousands
of phases at this point just a ton of
fun of phases and so so 6,000 pieces and
so for each face they have these nice
high-resolution 3d images okay and so
they're sort of very densely sampled
right but they're very sort of there's a
lots of complicated structure there and
so for each space they have over 7,000
points in 3d space they also have a
bunch of demographic information and a
bunch of genetic information and again
you sort of might want to do some
statistical modeling in terms of
understanding how do the shapes of these
phases how are they influenced by
different demographic variables or
genetic mutations or something like this
so these are just serves three data
examples that I deal with that you might
consider why I think they're sort of
interesting from a privacy point of view
although by basically dealing
statistical modeling okay so but those
are the sorts of things which motivate a
lot of my work okay so let's just get
into a sort of a statistical problem
just as you can understand a little bit
more what we might try and do in terms
of statistical modeling and where the
privacy might be a concern or might come
in so unlike a lot of some of the stuff
that you maybe are used to seeing and
privacy I deal a lot with functions okay
so I'm interested in parameters and
things as functions so not just as as
vectors or scalars okay and so in the
simplest case you can imagine having
something like a following model so you
have data that you're observing X I and
you're observing that them at say some
domain locations like these are ages and
then you could assume that this is
basically some mean right plus there
right so this is hopefully you're sort
of used to seeing these sorts of models
the only sort of weird
part about this is that you have this
this sort of function part right where
the MU is actually allowed to depend
sort of into some sort of nice way
depending on what the domain location is
and you have these errors and the errors
are there's lots of correlation if I'm
looking at errors from the same subject
all right and so in this context mu this
is your mean function that you might be
interested in estimating say like
average sort of the average trajectory
of weight over Heights for children the
epsilon I so this is now some subject
specific deviation and the T's these are
observed time domain ones all right so
to estimate the MU right so that would
be the statistical goal how do I
actually estimate this mu you there's a
whole bunch of tools so this is sort of
a whole branch called so functional data
analysis or nonparametric smoothing and
so probably the most popular are safe
smoothing splines I think that's usually
one of the first ones we we go to if you
don't like things like basis functions
you can use something called local
linear or local polynomial regression
which is just go locally and you fit a
linear or polynomial model but you sort
of let that vary smoothly over the
domain you can use what are called
reproducing kernel Hilbert spaces which
I've sort of taken liking to a lot
recently or you can just sort of use
general basis expansions to try and sort
of say well this mu that's some like
linear combination of some basis all
right and so the optimal estimation rate
in some sense is known under some
assumptions so I gather the folks and
some folks around here like lower bounds
and things like this I don't usually
talk too much about this but if you have
if you're estimating this mu and you
assume that it's a has like our
derivatives like say in l2 or something
all right then the optimal estimation
rate can actually be written down like
as follows right so you basically have
something like 1 over n so 1 over the
sample size and then you get something
like n times n right but how much
information so this is sort of like the
number of subjects times the number of
points per subject
right so but how much information you're
getting here it's sort of there's sort
of a limiting effect right so if I'm
trying to learn about the population I
can only get so much information from
one individual right I get something but
at some point sort of teeters out right
so you see here that if you had like R
which is huge right then this would look
very similar to this you get this like
minus one but it but it's not right so
it's it's gonna be something like two or
so okay so here you can sort of see the
interplay between the number of points
per subject and the sample size okay so
I was asked to do a problem session so I
was just going to talk a little bit
about some of these lower bounds for
folks like that sort of thing I think on
was it
alright ok so but I'm not gonna talk
about minimax things or anything like
this
I just just to give you a flavor the
mate my main goal is basically the
following so I have so we have this Mew
but I can just gonna replace the replace
this with some general parameter so I
have some parameter theta right but this
is now a function okay and it's they
like some smooth function or something
ok
and so that function is based on some
sort of model and I'm estimating it from
my data so I end up with something like
theta hat deep right so that could be
something like a spline or some sort of
RK just method or whatever and so I want
to produce a sanitized version data till
the D right which is private right or
epsilon or epsilon Delta Prime ok so
that's the sort of general setup and
then the sort of the story of mind you
can you can sort of think back to that
meaning all right ok so the way that I
want to do this is not too surprising
hopefully is that I basically want to
take whatever that estimate is and I
want to add on some random process right
ok so it sort of been studied on how to
do this if this is a a Gaussian process
so the Z T is Gaussian so what I want to
talk about today is when the Z is
actually not necessarily Gaussian using
some other options all right however if
you're doing something like this you can
still sort of talk about what does it
mean to satisfy epsilon Delta privacy or
epsilon privacy right so you basically
have the same definition right I do some
I take some adjacent database right I
swap out some say units like some
subjects some child and then I recompute
the estimate the question is how far
away could the sort of new estimate and
the old estimate be from each other
right ok so you get the same sort of
bound ok for those that really really
like measure theory I don't know how
many of you fall into that group there
is actually an interesting question here
about this has to hold for some sets and
the question is well if these are
functions what does that mean right and
what sorts of sets are we talking about
ok so there's actually some weird
measure theoretic things that come up
which I'm gonna try and avoid now but
again folks I'm talking about that week
okay alright so there are there is a
fair amount of a related work at this
point
when we got into this research over and
you know of other papers certainly we
know but when we got into this reverse
are really aware of polymer and aldo and
watch women's work which looked at
Gaussian perturbations really focus on
point wise releases although they had
some interesting extensions and
different ways and then there was some
work which was not maybe not quite
functional or sort of related and then
recently was not about recently more but
you know a sign of other things so we
looked at basically Gaussian
perturbations over Banach and Hilbert
spaces so much sort of more generally
than just sort of point where and
releases so we had this sort of very
broad framework and we also looked at an
exponential mechanism over Hilbert
spaces which I don't think we're gonna
talk about any time during this this
week but again this it's sort of a fun
project because there's also weird
things that come up in there there's
also a paper which I'm waiting on from a
friend
Aurora delaio who works in statistics
not too much in data privacy that sort
of looking at density estimation and
Brownian motion perturbations and that's
some interesting stuff there but that's
still not that out okay
all right so so I've said that I want to
use the elliptical distributions to do
privacy so a good question is well what
what's an elliptical distribution it
seems like a good good starting point so
electrical distribution intuitively it
can just be thought of as sort of a
generalization of a Gaussian so in the
in the following sense so if you think
about a Gaussian distribution just say
think about a bivariate Gaussian
distribution alright and you plot it if
you cut it right you take the level sets
of the distribution
you'll get ellipses alright so this is
one of those things so it turns out
though that's not the only distribution
that that will happen for right so there
are others and so any distribution where
this happens is basically called an
elliptical distribution right if I take
the level sets of the density and I get
an ellipse that's called an elliptical
distribution so mathematic you can be a
little this or not this the top ones not
1% precise but do be a little bit more
precise in the sense that you can choose
sort of one or two definitions if you
like so you and I looked a good
distribution is one where basically the
density up to say some constants based
on the parameters it's proportional to
some function of this sort of quadratic
form okay and so if I'm looking at sort
of the level sets basically the level
sets are really gonna be determined by
this guy which is the formula for an
ellipse basically and so this function
though it can be sort of anything it
couldn't even be infinite as long as
it's not infinite for too long and then
you have something like a center and
something like a scale right so if
everything has finite moments and then
you can have a meaning of covariance but
the elliptical just we don't have that
final moments they can have very heavy
tails which is part of the reason why we
would look at them in which case you can
think of again the Meuse are more of a
center and the Sigma is more of like a
scaling an alternative is to use
characteristic functionals okay so very
closely related to Fourier transforms
you like but the nice thing about using
characteristic functions or functionals
is that they sort of completely describe
distributions and you don't have to
worry about things like oh it's Sigma
invertible or not so with the
characteristic functional basically you
can get this sort of same set the same
sort of structure so if X has the sort
of following characteristic function
you'd save it so it's elliptical so
basically you have some mean which just
sort of factors out so you don't really
worry about that and then you have this
sort of central component which sort of
just depends on the server and a nice
certain quadratic form yeah it actually
it has to be decreasing yeah it actually
this was something we we could tell we
were trying to like really convince
ourselves could it possibly increase
okay it has to it has to be research so
it actually has to be monotonically
decreasing you can think that you can
come of weird stuff like if you slight
if it's not mono talking you start
slicing it okay so in general I usually
calm you the center or location again
just because the moments get a little
bit awkward ball Sigma is called the
scale or dispersion matrix again just
think of them as meaning covariance
matrices but they mean and covariance
might not exist okay all right so the
nice thing is that actually the
elliptical distributions extend very
nicely to infinite dimensions which are
sort of part of the motivation right so
part of the problem is using Gaussian
perturbations and privacy is that you
you can't get epsilon privacy you can
only have epsilon Delta right because
you don't have thick enough tails so you
can move to something like I'm
elliptical distribution which gives you
thicker tails which is nice and then the
other nice aspect is that elliptical
distributions extend very nicely to
elliptical processors okay so they're
just sort of it's almost immediate so
basically with the stochastic process so
now you can think of basically having
like infinitely many random variables
right so a stochastic process is called
elliptical if all of the sort of finite
dimensional distributions those are
elliptical distributions from the same
family
all right and so I sort of right in this
general tea here for the domain usually
you think of it just being zero one
although there's other occasions where
you might want to be more complex and
the nice thing here is that yeah so this
allows you to really get thicker tail so
yep Gaussian is one example but you can
have Laplace distributions Laplace
processes you know T processes you can
have Kochi processes and really there
are formulas for getting sort of
infinitely many families of elliptical
process so you can really tailor these
things and actually because of that
they've become pretty popular in like
extreme value spatial modeling because
they can sort of try to model tails a
lot better using these sorts of
elliptical distribution okay right okay
so but if you have a sort of an
elliptical process then what you can
sort of show is that well there has to
be some sort of center to that process
and some sort of scale or covariance to
that process as well okay so it's it's
sort of very similar to a Gaussian
process you have a mean sort of function
then you have some Co brains function
describing of things of dependent in
time and but now you'd have thicker
tails instead Gausman tails
but
all right so it turns out that this is
sort of already enough to define a
notion of sensitivity it's a little bit
premature cuz you really need to know
what the noise is before I mean you'd
really need to nail them some more
specifics usually but this turns out to
be enough so if you take this covariance
function the CT of s right so this is
actually sort of a nice positive
definite symmetric function okay and so
to that function there's actually a very
special space associated with it right
and in particular you can form what's
called a reproducing kernel Hilbert
space for those that are familiar with
those sorts of things but every produces
I'll sort of talk about this in a second
it also has another sort of special name
called the Cameron Martin space which it
just sort of depends on the field you're
in but what this space basically
consists of is this consists of
functions from your domain into R right
but they have to be somewhat nice and
they have to be nice in the sense that
they satisfy this sort of following this
is called the reproducing property so
basically these sort of these sort of
functions right here this see T of s so
for each fixed T as a function of s that
thing has to be inside this space and
then you also get this nice let's call
the reproducing property if I form the
inner product of CT with any other
function f then that gives me point
minus evaluation okay so a sort of a set
of functions where you have this sort of
properties typically called the
reproducing kernel Hilbert space right
it's Hilbert and it reproduces it hasn't
it has a kernel that's the kernel but
they've heard this what there's this
actually there's nice one correspondence
between the two okay it turns out that
that space is the sort of right space
for calculating sensitivity and so in
particular if you want to sort of
calculate global sensitivity what you
really want to do is you want to say
okay in that space if I sort of swap out
one subject how much could my statistic
change okay in that norm
oh sure yeah this is just this so you
can think about is like point so if
again if you have moments you can just
think of it as basically describing the
covariance so if I look at see T of s
that's the covariance of X of T and X of
s but the codes might not exist do you
want to go really crazy like you want to
go all the way to Koshi it doesn't
okay so this is really the right space
for for computing sensitivity which is
which is sort of one of these things
that was brought up in Holland Ronaldo
and Wasserman actually but it extends
very very broadly actually so this if
you want to add on some noise it turns
out that this space for that noise this
is really the crucial thing to look at
and if that if you're sort of statistic
is not falling into that that space then
it turns out you actually can't do
privacy so that is so you can't
guarantee something like epsilon or
epsilon Delta privacy okay so this is
this is the sensitive it's known a
priori it's sort of like saying that I'm
an adding alternate gaussian
multivariate gaussian right and I don't
necessarily know the constant I'm gonna
put in front but I've selected a
covariance so it's not it's the C is not
data dependent this has to be chosen
beforehand but you can have a scaly yeah
but do you also assume your data it's
actually generated from this no that's
not necessary
what's necessary what's necessary is
that the summary the statistic that
you're calculating actually falls in so
this fits in very nicely with
reproducing kernel Hilbert space
regression because when you estimate
your parameters you put penalties that
actually force the statistics to fall
into the space so if it's very nice is
there the data itself can actually be
atrocious yeah so there's there's a
sense in which the data can fall into
some pretty nasty spaces as long as the
statistics are
okay so alright so here's I just have
now a few results and then they can talk
for go to lunch so this is the first so
this is basically epsilon privacy for a
point what sort of finite number of
point where slip releases okay so
suppose that you're gonna fix some
domain points t1 through TV right and so
suppose you're using some centered
elliptical process right to add on to
your statistic right then what you can
show basically is that you can get
epsilon privacy right using this process
and the really the only thing you need
to check so you need your sort of finite
sensitivity but the really the only
thing you need to check is you need to
go back to this function that we sort of
started with and said okay this is this
elliptical density up to some constants
right and that's just I mean this this
is a function just from our car and we
need to do sort of a little check right
so basically what needs to happen is
that it needs to be the case that this F
is say bounded above so I can't go off
to infinity so that would be true since
it's decreasing that would be true as
long as it starts at something finite
and then you basically need to show that
as you sort of go out into the tails of
this F that things are gonna be okay
right so which is hopefully intuitively
what you sort of think about the problem
with the Gaussian right is that the
tails don't work right and this is
basically sort of saying that okay in a
very broad sense you can sort of check
this so you can have any sort of
complicated process processes but it's
really it's just this single function
you have to check okay and I'll show you
maybe some examples where it's actually
pretty easy to check and if you have
this then basically what you have is you
have this relationship you basically
have epsilon privacy right where this is
the epsilon that you have and you have a
Sigma squared there which scales the
noise so you can move Sigma right to get
the epsilon that you need
so there's a nice sense in which okay
from multivariate summaries you can have
epsilon privacy and you can have it sort
of for the into some sort of arbitrary
sense arbitrary points add on this noise
and then you'll get it alright so just
for example just to see if some some
interesting stuff so if you so ignore
this Sigma just to make things a little
simpler so if I start with a Gaussian
and I form this ratio I talked about
right then basically it'll simplify into
something like this right and as I take
C to infinity I get something which goes
to infinity so the tails of the Gaussian
are not right so as we all know if the
Gaussian will not work right you can't
have epsilon privacy with the Gaussian
because the tails just don't the tails
are to blow up on you all right when you
take ratios it blows up in the wrong way
okay if you go to T distributions right
so the T distribution looks like this so
this is this is the form of the F for
multivariate team okay and then if you
basically look at this ratio okay if I I
don't have to worry about these powers
you basically it's not too hard to admit
yourself that as C goes to infinity this
is sort of the dominating term and it
goes to one and everything is okay right
so T distributions can do Epsilon
privacy which hopefully is not too
surprising one thing that is somewhat
surprising which we were not expecting
is that the Laplace distribution cannot
be used for epsilon privacy in any
dimension except for one right
not expecting now just to stress this
this is a multivariate Laplace so this
is an elliptical applause that's which
does not include a ideal applause as a
special case so if you look at the
Laplace then actually this is the form
of this f so you get a square root of x
and then you get something what's called
a modified Bessel function which there's
some reason keeps coming up in my work
and I hate it because it's the most fun
intuitive function I think I've ever
seen
but there is at least a few things you
can look at it you can sort of know
about this and if you actually look at
this structure what ends up happening is
that if you take X at 0 if you take X to
0 this thing actually blows up on you in
every dimension except for one so if you
go to two dimensions you get this pole
so actually it's fine in the tails
Laplace is financed tails
did you get this like infinite pole at
zero which breaks everything which we
were not expecting I thought that would
be the perfect
Thanks okay okay and so here's the the
negative result and this was something I
really I really was not expecting and I
was trying very hard to prove that it
wasn't true but it turns out that it is
so the the negative result actually is
that while you can have epsilon privacy
in multivariate data in finite
dimensions you cannot have epsilon
privacy with an elliptical distribution
in infinite dimensions that is exact
mathematically impossible in some sense
and by infinite I mean like truly
infinite so there's not like some finite
dimensional low rank structure sitting
there to simplify everything so if
everything is truly infinite and I'm
removing sort of pathological examples
like I always output zero or something
for my statistic then you can't have you
can't have privacy or the into the
infinite dimensional space and so I
really I'd really didn't think that
would be the case so this this is
interesting cuz it's telling you like
even for the Koshi
right so Kochi which has like no finite
mean no finite variance right huge thick
tails if you try and do this in infinite
dimensions you can't have epsilon
privacy so you can mathematically show
you can't have it and the reason is
actually like in hindsight once we were
looking it wasn't maybe too surprising
the problem actually is that the
elliptical distributions are too
connected to Gaussian processes right
and it turns out that in finite
dimensions it's not necessarily a
problem but in infinite dimensions
there's actually you can actually learn
too much about the process and start
making tuning connections to Gaussian
processes and then you could break
everything right so for example if you
think about the Laplace distribution so
one of these little facts that that
sometimes you learn is that the Laplace
distribution you can actually generate
their Laplace by first generating a
normal and generating an exponential and
you basically see it I think you scale
about the square root of an exponential
right so what that's telling you is that
in the Laplace right you have epsilon
privacy but if I told you what that
exponential was right what I did this
release then that would be telling you
I'm back basically to the Gaussian world
and it turns out that for any pin
two-dimensional processes that that's
exactly the problem you actually can
learn too much about how you're scaling
things
nothing nothing works so anyway so
that's er that was sort of a negative
result we weren't expecting but it's
sort of fun and it holds for those that
are interested again it holds like in
very broad spaces so it holds in
something called locally convex vector
spaces include almost every space I know
of Hilbert spaces Banach spaces fresshe
spaces which I don't ever work with but
includes them too so it's a pretty broad
thing the positive though is that you
still have epsilon Delta privacy which I
mean I'm fine with although I think a
lot of people would prefer something
stronger so as long as you have Delta
greater than 0 it turns out that you can
get epsilon Delta privacy you have a
little bit of a weird connection it in
terms of getting what exactly the Delta
is right and trying to get it scaled in
the right way but you can't do it so you
can add epsilon Delta privacy name pin
dimensions but you can't have the
epsilon not with elliptical
distributions but they're sort of a nice
okay so so with that I don't suppose you
go to okay good cuz I think that's a
little heavy for right before lunch but
overall I just sort of general
conclusions are just that so the
elliptical distributions are really nice
in in one regard right so they're very
natural extensions of Gaussian
distributions so if you want to start
moving away from Gaussian distributions
then elliptical seems quite natural it
includes things like Laplace right which
is maybe a good thing and so and they're
relatively easy to work with once you
sort of learn a few tricks and so the
increased sort of heavier tails they can
provide increased privacy which is nice
however if you're in multivariate and so
that those sort of heavier tails in
multivariate world right you can get
epsilon privacy but it turns out that if
you want sort of the complete protection
of the functions it turns out that's
they're still too restrictive if you
actually want epsilon privacy there okay
so with that I'll just call it
we have plenty of time for questions if
anyone has questions thoughts my same
annoying question so how come so
computationally how would you you know
simple uh you know I mean I know I've
been do gaussians yeah variance there's
actually this is the other nice thing
about lip tickles is there's actually
fear there's a couple strategies for
generating them which is basically as
hard as generating a Gaussian so there's
there's usually two forms there's one
form which is actually there's sort of
like a random scaling of a Gaussian
process you can do which is very simple
there's also things like you can
decompose it into like you know angle
and our radius and do something like
that
so there actually it's quite it's
actually quite nice
very good sure okay I'm really curious
about this this lower bond man without
what as I say are you restricting
anything on the kind of noise that
you're adding to this process for the
epsilon privacy negatives are boundless
as any noise adding mechanism that as
something with the stochastic processes
and you say that you cannot possibly
achieve
right so yes it's good it's good to
emphasize this point it's specific to
the Z so that is to say that is to say
if I fix this Z and the only thing I'm
allowed to adjust is just the scale
factor like I'm gonna multiply by
something right that cannot cheat
elliptic that cannot achieve epsilon
privacy if that Z is elliptical but it's
not but it's not an arbitrary noise so
there are noises you could add which
conceivably would give you epsilon
privacy comes track one specific boys
hiding procedure that works here and it
also gives you the function you first do
like a wavelet transform rock your
function you add noise calibrated
according to the l1 sensitivity you had
the plus noise to every coordinate and
then you transform it back sure so that
it's as long as as long as the as long
as the noise that you're adding it's as
long as it decreases in the right way
then that work usually so and can be
generalized quite broadly so the issue
this you have is that you want to add on
noise in a way that doesn't delete the
space and that can be potentially
problematic so I does this say if I'm in
l2 and I do some expansion and I add on
like iid to every coefficient or
something I'm no longer in l2 so you
just have to be you just have to watch
that but as long as you do that you can
have them decrease in those that were
close you first convert everything to
the sequence space you have a finite
dimensional
because you gotta you've got to do the
stress shooting anyways so then you can
finite-dimensional noise and right well
so and that's what I mean by that's what
I mean um that's what I mean by you have
to sort of eliminate it's a truly
infinite dimensional problem so as you
see if I'm willing to project everything
to finite dimensions I see and work
there then you're fine so not a whole
display space or bet self space kind of
well those are those spaces have these
still be be surrendered the pathological
problems yeah infinite but they go very
quickly yeah yeah yeah I guess my
question was sort of I'm gonna be
similar to your Shang so I'll see if I
can make it more precise but I I guess I
was wondering you mentioned there are a
few different approaches that one could
take to releasing a differentiate
private very functional summary oh yeah
and so I I was I'm trying to understand
what like how how different they really
are and if there are sort of specific
uses that you could sort of like opera
operational differences between them
like some tasks that you want to
accomplish that somehow you can do with
some of these approaches and and not
with others or something like that like
they they all feel like they're doing
something very similar sure sure I think
they are I think they are doing
something for the so I think that for me
the interesting point is just that how
do sort of how do you as you start
moving into these like later spectrum
right sort of move these higher
frequencies like what what are you going
what are you going to do to regularize
like what are you going to do to fix
this problem because the problem is like
as you start moving into those sort of
higher dimensions this is sort of when
things get a little bit more junky or
they're sort of more individual specific
and these are the things you have to
kill right so you can threshold right
but you can also smooth which is to say
I'm not I'm not Thresh holding I'm just
requiring that they sort of as
emphatically at least decrease at a
particular rate
and that's moving that's virtually
missing mystics no it's not but it's not
it's not threshold anyway it's not
threshold
scaling it down or something right and
then anything that the nice thing here
is that if you do it sort of in this
higher dimensional space you can then do
any post thing you want right you can
take any approach that you particular
you like right and it's guaranteed to
transfer privacy to any of those
approaches so it doesn't have to be
privacy sort of within the context of
this specific algorithm our thresholding
routine or something like this so I
guess like just see if I can nail it
down a little more like these approaches
where you first do some transform it
into some basis and work with that sort
of sequence representation you know
you're saying the advantage of sort of
working directly in a functional space
is that you're not you not kind of in
the tail you're not setting those higher
frequencies to zero or it's it's that
they've been I sit there they're sort of
forced to sort of come down in a
reasonable way so so put another way
some point they're scaling down so
quickly that you might as well make them
fit I guess yeah so they might be my
hands I'm like is there is there some
like specific tasks that you can
accomplish and ooh using this sort of
infant you know working directly to the
internet dimensional reputation that is
just impossible if you kind of use some
of these other approaches so I mean
that's a hard question to answer answer
but I'll just point out one one
particular point right the fact this
when you take this limit right so let's
say is you like sort of let the
truncation sort of get you know weaker
and weaker and you let it go to infinity
right you might think that you get
something which is private in a sort of
infinite dimensional space right but
what basically this result is showing is
that actually you don't you it does not
it does not absalom private it's a best
epsilon-delta private and okay why is
that happening well it turns out that
how you truncate right and how much
noise you add it depends too much on
where you truncate it it depends too
much on the dimension right and so at
first for epsilon privacy right so you
let that thing grow
grabs on privacy breaks and so you might
not I would just say this is sort of an
hissing point that you're actually gonna
have this feature that the sort of noise
that you're adding it has to keep
scaling up as you sort of let that
dimension grow and you might think that
okay
those are jump dimensions I don't need
to worry about them but as emphatically
you need to you typically let those
things
I think you're the answer my question so
maybe was anyways uh try sewing okay
take a look often we have this sort of
negative is underneath an international
setting that that's sort of I think not
always for sometimes to be refreshes if
you let their magical TV something's
blowing up
yeah that's definitely what's happening
yeah that's that's I think that's an
intuitive way of do of handling so
basically what this is what our result
says that okay for a fixed dimension
there is a sigma that will give you the
epsilon privacy but as you let that
dimension increase that Sigma is not
well behaved right but what's
interesting is that for epsilon Delta
privacy the Sigma is well behaved so
this is sort of like an interesting
contrast in my mind yeah so I guess one
could also define similar distributions
for you where your level sets are not
necessarily ellipses but right yeah if
you do the two norm you're back to an
ellipse but yeah other norms yeah yeah
that's right I mean how much of this can
be extended the Google distributions
regenitive like some norm I don't think
you can such thing it's it's very
specific to this elliptical structure so
that is I mean but that is to say that
this is this is to me a good thing
because I think it means something like
these strategies I think are have a
better chance of of giving you this
infinite dimensional property so I think
it's a good thing it doesn't matter